Speaker 1: So we're seeing increased concern,
not yet panic, but concern for now about the
spread of monkeypox, possibly through sexual
contact, which we're going to talk about
sort of as the second part of this story. So,
first of all, what is monkeypox? Monkeypox
is an infectious disease, a communicable disease
that can be transmitted between animals and people
and also between people is caused by the monkeypox
virus. The symptoms are initially fever, headache,
muscle pain, swollen lymph nodes and feeling
tired. And then later you get this rash that
forms blisters, which crust over. And in that
sense, it's in the kind of universe of smallpox,
chickenpox, etc.. The type from when you're the
time, from when you're exposed until you get
symptoms is typically around ten days, which,
as you can imagine, can make contact tracing
potentially more difficult. And the
duration of symptoms is typically 2 to 4
weeks. It can look a lot like chickenpox in humans
and the ways that it spreads. Unlike COVID, it
does not tend to spread through aerosolized virus
particles, although it's conceivable that if you
have respiratory involvement, it could spread in
that way. But primarily, monkeypox spreads through
the handling of what's called bushmeat, through
being bit by an animal or scratched by an animal
carrying it. And then between humans,
it can spread through bodily fluids,
contaminated objects, close contact with other
humans who have it. The smallpox vaccine,
not the monkeypox vaccine. The smallpox vaccine is
believed to be about 85% effective at preventing
monkeypox. And then in 2019, a monkeypox vaccine
called and I hope I'm pronouncing this correctly,
genius, also known as M van necks in the European
Union and information in Canada was approved for
adults in the United States. So that's monkeypox,
what's happening in this particular outbreak.
Earlier this month, several cases were
identified in London and one in northeast
England. Portugal and Spain have reported
several cases. And then a case was confirmed
in Massachusetts by the CDC after a man traveled
to Canada. Potentially, there's a case in New
York City that's under investigation. And health
officials are investigating what is believed to be
Florida's first positive case. It's a presumptive
positive case in south Florida. That case
appears to be related to international travel,
and that person is isolated. The Canadian nexus is
that earlier this month in Quebec, two cases were
confirmed. 20 more are still under investigation
in Canada. So how is it spreading? What's the
connection here? The W.H.O. right now is working
on a sexual contact theory. This is very early.
We don't have all the details. But David Heyman
from the W.H.O. spoke to Reuters and is working
on the idea that there seems to be a possible
sexual contact kind of chain in a number of
the cases so far. Heymann said, quote, What
seems to be happening now is that it's got into
the population as a sexual form, a genital form,
and is being spread as a sexually transmitted
infection, which has amplified its transmission
around the world very early. Important
things. And if you're wondering, oh, no,
are there already conspiracy theories about
monkeypox? Yes, there are. And we're going to
get to the momentarily. But if you're wondering,
number one, is this likely to trigger a global
COVID type response? The answer is almost
certainly not. This spreads differently.
It's less contagious. And we're going to deal
with that kind of in the conspiracy segment.
And number two, is this, strictly speaking, a
sexually transmitted disease? Strictly speaking,
it's not. But it is a disease that can be spread
through sexual contact. And we're going to have
more information about that as we continue to
learn about this. But that's the latest from
the show and other authorities on monkeypox.
Yes. Let's talk about the conspiracy theories